para Ucrania era una decisión entre el
bien y el mal el resultado abrumador 141
países respaldaron una resolución en la
que la asamblea general de Naciones
Unidas Pide a Rusia Cesar las
hostilidades en Ucrania y que se retire
de manera inmediata se apela además a
una paz justa y duradera
una resolución con un gran apoyo pero
sin poder vinculante porque Rusia es uno
de los integrantes del Consejo de
Seguridad el órgano llamado a velar por
el mantenimiento de la paz internacional
y por tanto Moscú cuenta con derecho de
veto en La
ilegal en un mundo en el que el uso
ilegal de la fuerza por parte de un
miembro permanente del Consejo de
Seguridad Por cierto Está normalizado no
hay esperanza para el progreso la
justicia y la libertad
y Nicaragua se opusieron a la resolución
de este jueves hubo 32 naciones que se
absorbieron Incluyendo a China que ha
prometido hacer una propuesta para una
política al conflicto ya Son seis las
resoluciones que este organismo de
Naciones Unidas ha aprobado desde la
invasión rusa y para Ucrania son una
muestra del posicionamiento global ante
esta guerra
la votación de hoy es otra muestra de
evidencia como he dicho que no solamente
occidente apoya a Ucrania el apoyo es
mucho más amplio y solamente seguirá
para ser consolidado y solidificado
culminan así dos días de discursos de
respaldo a Ucrania en la víspera del
primer aniversario del conflicto un
conflicto más incierto que nunca pero
con algunas certezas Para algunas
naciones como Alemania según su ministra
de exteriores si Rusia deja de combatir
la guerra termina pero si Ucrania deja
de combatir la que se acaba es la propia
Ucrania